urubus pessoal de mais um vídeo e hoje
os sinais que fazer uma idéia do número
muito simples e com materiais muito
básicos que vocês provavelmente vão ter
em casa é tão por lá o tutorial passo
passa e depois podem ser assassinos
comunhão com a fã embora lá pessoal
primeira necessidade desta imagem e vou
deixar o link do tempo foi com a
descrição vocês vão lá mas a imagem que
vão encontrar não vai estar a medida não
bastará escala então o que vocês vão
fazer mas sempre vão contar os
condôminos desenhar igualzinho em casa
uma vez com o papel quadriculado é
universal
depois de se vincular a para tu quer
fazer caixa no pedaço quanto ao ir
cortar a volta usando uma tesoura ou
então podem usar um x-ato e uma régua
mas atenção se vocês forem crianças
peçam ajuda o duto com o mesmo certeza
que não vai impactar nos ajudar e depois
executar
vamos dobrar pelos mesmos encargos
línguas podem usar a régua ou então
podem fazer na borda da mesa final é só
tirar o papel para o trabalhador hoje
agora vamos fazer a lâmina na verdade
para fazer lá não gostar de fazer dois
modos como este
a diferença do modo para o outro é com
vai ter um retângulo é menos extra tango
que estou fazer e que agora
para nós a lâmina durar mais tempo com
vai reforçar a estrutura uma vez que o
plano é frágil para isso usei português
do picolé
as duas filas de cima abaixo da lâmina
na parte final na parte mais larga
conca e 2006 muito pequeninos são muito
importante na parte do trovador lâmina
para que ela não sai disparada de caixa
por isso não esqueçam por esses dois
poderes são muito importantes
afinal é só pôr bastante cola e colar
outra parte do modo possível
veja aqui a lâmina
agora vamos colar estudo assim impedindo
o plantio de picolé é 90 ângulo que tira
de cena para trás e não de frente está a
ser muito importante na parte traseira o
gatilho e claro que só vocês vão ter que
cortar a ponta para não se deixarem cair
segurança é acima de tudo agora vão
precisar de um vasto que é usado pelas
costureiras que é bem resistente e
esticar bastante por um quinto com ela
não para de tampa da caixa
la rue la a se dedicar ao máximo pronto
marcão e corta
depois disso vamos colar é caixa nesta
parte final só pra ser mais fácil depois
trabalharmos e tem um filho a noção do
espaço interior
por lá dentro e colar a outra ponta do
elástico na parte final da liga
corta em quatro dos cinco mil de um
convênio do picolé e vamos pular na
parte frontal na partida é caixa acaba
pois estariam querendo inclui dois
políticos novos casos pode ser preciso
um todo tenha mais o planeta - portanto
aquela mina travou lá e também não ficar
apertado ok vocês vão ver e pronto
se tiver bom é deixar ele jogar aqui a
parte do mecanismo tem um retângulo da
caixa o retângulo e agora pronto já não
temos mais nada a fazer lá dentro da
caixa e vamos fechar usando bastante col
eu escutava quando tem mais ou menos a
maio sobrepor um ao outro dessa pequena
distância na quarta frente nem para trás
vamos cortar para deixar ao mesmo nível
nos foram querido colo pelo torneio
feminino e colar maior
isso depois de ficar
temos que fazer uma marcação de charlie
um dedo mais um dos dedos
vamos fazer corte em v atenção se vocês
forem crianças peço ajuda o duto como
vocês usarem luvas de proteção e 8
pronta ela não estava muito afiada então
eu fiz assim a precisar de um pontinho
do churrasco ou então pulei tentou então
pode ser também um forte choque e um
crime do fio votar o fio ao pleito vocês
tiverem e vamos pôr a pecinha ensino
atenção nesta parte do tempo tentando
fazer que voltas em oito mais ou menos
vejam aqui até mesmo em cidades 05 ti
inside 1&tp psf móvel é para acionar o
objetivo é e agora os porque o pneu cola
colar um pedacinho do elástico
depois ficar no outro lado os pacs e
agora só para essa geringonça tudo o que
vocês estão vendo aí para importados
pelos índios do popular e colar em cima
fica mais bonita que é mais discreto
sistema e agora o funcionamento e quando
os gatos no chicão sobre o poste um em
cima do outro acontece é que todos os
pelo inpi no centro do retângulo da
lâmina e travou ela pois quando você
pressiona os produtinhos os pontinhos
saem do retângulo - a disparada no vista
em villach empurrá lá para frente e só
chegamos a fios perto o estado se vocês
gostaram beijo mesmo já chegou aí eu
posso favorito e se inscreva no canal
que estuda ajudar bastante a edificação
evolução do meu trabalho
muito obrigada em grande abraço